der frust über die deutsche corona
politik der entlädt sich ausgerechnet
auf der schlagerbühne dieses video das
geht gerade virale frust rede von
schlagersänger bernhard brink auf der
berliner waldbühne
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie sind los
toni
könnte kommen finde ich konnte das ging
ja auch
der schlagersänger bernhard brink und
seine corona frust rede das ganze fand
statt bei der aufzeichnung zu schlager
nach gezeigt wurde das dann im fernsehen
übrigens nicht im rbb raus geschnitten
und in der deutschen corinna debatte
wird ein thema jetzt immer größer das
lange auch raus geschnitten wurde im
nebenwirkungen impfschäden auch die
bundesregierung erkennt inzwischen
offenbar dass man dieses thema
fälschlicherweise lange tabuisiert hat
karl lauterbach vergleichen sie mal
diese beiden teams hier früher hat er
von der nebenwirkungsfreien impfung
gesprochen heute sagt auch lauterbach ja
wir müssen diese impfnebenwirkungen
besser erforschen aber eben vor einem
jahr
nebenwirkungsfreie impfung das war der
satz von karl lauterbach
nebenwirkungsfrei wie konnte lauterbach
das plus behaupten der top 4 o logi
klaus stöhr mitglied des
sachverständigen gremium der
bundesregierung der hat sich hier im
bild studium abend im bildstock die
richtigen fragen darüber aufgeregt wer
von nebenwirkungsfreie impfung sprecher
der dürfe nicht als arzt arbeiten sagt
er die engländer seien loose cannon für
jemand der im prinzip nicht so zu
steuern ist ein arzt der das werk sollte
keine approbation haben punkt 1 ein arzt
der sagt nebenwirkungsfrei ist die
impfung sollte keine approbation erregt
das ja für jemand der als bundesminister
egal wo er sitzt kommuniziert würde ich
mehr
bodenständigkeit
verantwortungsbewusstsein
strategie langfristiges denken erhoffen
und mehr auch eine bessere vorbereitung
das heißt sie hätten das niemals getan
sie hätten zum damaligen zeitpunkt gar
nicht jedes medikament hatte
nebenwirkungen jedes es geht gar nicht
anders karl lauterbach er solle seine
arzt zulassung dann zurückgeben dieser
satz schlägt wählen heute früh gesagt
hierbei bild im bild ort die richtigen
fragen